hello everyone I'm Alana say hi to
YouTube twitch chat um we are streaming
the first hopefully four hours of
Callisto protocol live on Twitch right
now I am very very excited about this
game have been very excited about this
game just since it got announced just
Bonkers levels of excited
um I've seen that there are some mixed
reviews but I just intentionally did not
read any of them because I just want to
experience it fresh without thinking
about anyone else's opinions uh and yeah
for any of you who don't already know
about this game
uh it came out December 2nd I was hoping
to stream at launch day but had a bunch
of Internet issues so here we are a
couple of days late unfortunately I've
like been trying so hard to avoid
spoilers but it's very dead Spacey it is
single player third person sci-fi
survival horror
and you have to try to escape uh I think
it's black Iron prison is the whole goal
looks like lots of monsters lots of
people getting like decapitated lots of
gory stuff happening I'm sure YouTube is
going to demonetize this immediately but
that's okay we don't mind uh I am yeah
I'm super super excited to play it so
let's jump in also playing this at 7am
in the morning is like
I may be cheating a little like like
that's a good chance I avoid being too
scared ah I say that but I'm an absolute
baby when it comes to food you don't
have to scroll all these okay I'm a big
old baby when it comes to video games so
maybe not maybe not
yeah just assuming that the that the
rules of conduct uh are chill seizure
warning appreciate that thank you this
game is a work of fiction all names
characters places and incidents
portrayed in this game are products of
the imagination of the development team
or used fictitiously
though I do know Sam Whitwell a friend
of mine who very strongly
um is part of the reason that I ended up
uh fostering German Shepherds
um he really talked me into it
uh I know he's in the game okay let's go
to medium
I'm gonna need to go
here
the glare in this room is unfortunate I
really should do something about that
eventually
twitch let me know how the audio is
please
expect this to start this way my God
I thought we were on
um
like I expected it to look more prisony
but I guess it starts outside of one one
hour implants
damn
only fans popping off
so many particles
that's a lot of spores
oh I'm playing on Xbox by the way um
by choice because I was planning to play
the game while traveling so I to take a
load off my pc
uh again I'm not traveling now I just
couldn't get the game to work while
traveling because of my internet speeds
but um at the stream to work by the way
I use the Xbox series s
because it's so small
to take a load off my pc
good job
how's the audio everybody
what are you okay
too quiet okay
you have something to say You're Gonna
Keep flicking that thing off the sweat
on his face
I was watching that
it's our last run Max damn I'm done
talking about it
and what do you want me to say well
thank you
because after this job we're never gonna
have to work another day in our lives
well I guess you got it all figured out
I guess so is that Sam
and what is this huh back and forth
Callisto to Europa all this additional
security it's a prison movie
they take the security pretty serious
and what about the attacks oh how do you
explain that dude that faces look
amazing targets all over the sector for
the past six months
we got a yellow light in the cargo holds
it is not sanding well it's still worth
checking out
shouldn't worry so much you know
live longer
even starboard sensors are both showing
errors go check them out the camera
angle oh
I feel so like so much Dead Space
Nostalgia even though like it's not a
spiritual successity Dead Space it is a
whole new game
dude I didn't expect this to look this
good
Jacob Lee Jacob's job press the d-pad up
to open the inventory press the right
bumper to select the data bios menu use
the d-pad to select database categories
and individual data bio entries press
the a button to view and click ok
so it's up
can you walk home okay oh you can't it's
funny look at him just like pivoting
around
done jobs like this before don't know
why he cares so much now
the job
your head down and your mouth shut
okay
oh my God this looks good
oh what kind of plant you got
um
that might be a pothos
I think it's probably a pothos
the cargo hold Jacob right what you need
him
joke
that's all it says
oh you have a pen it's right there
oh a basic okay cool
what does it say it normally detect it
of course of course always
you got any more what you needs down
here not so much
that's another pothos I think it is it
looks like it that's all I'm saying I
got a couple of those
oh this is a lot bigger than I expected
I don't want to explore before I
actually
oh nice neon toilet that's JDM as hell
so far great yeah
ew close your toothpaste
uh
oh this is a shower
cool I know that I overexplore things
but I have had a lot of people in demos
be like we really appreciate that you
check all of these nuts and currencies
somebody spent a long time designing
that whole way
thank you imagine eco
still very dark
this monitor is not great with uh
black
why does it already sound so spooky
that was pretty seamless
better be worth the trouble
I should check out the rest of the ship
landing gear
it's very claustrophobic oh that's a
good looking hallway
also no UI
no UI
you like that
this is not going to go well for me
[Laughter]
oh yes some steam in a section of the
game that isn't even scary that was
freaking me out too
because it looks like Pyramid Head at
the end of the hallway
okay maybe it does get scary quickly
sound design is sound designing
yeah these um
why Crescendo why crescendo
why Orchestra
foreign
I really appreciate how creepy the vibe
is with these big uh cloak things that
look like they're concealing humans I
think that is a very nice
spooky touch
why is music swell
music knows well
that seems bad
Max I got trouble oh we had a lot of
trouble dude we've been boarded
the other way yeah I'm guessing
would you get your ass back up here
back
okay oh well who locked that
I have to go through the file look how
sweaty this dude is
what's it uh what's his name Josh
something
all right
keep moving through the fire and the
Flames We Carry On
I wonder what he meant by Fire and
Flames
is that stealth or was that just to get
me to go under the
that's probably just for progression
um let me turn subtitles on for you all
maybe I guess subtitles
um
just
so that it helps also tell me if I need
to move the webcam
you dookie mookie thank you
Field's still in effect look do you have
running field still in effect
can we get a little damp in here
yeah what do they want I'm pretty
curious about that too
also this ship is huge
I feel like this must be expensive
where did I get the outfit from
we just started up with it
I don't know oh thank you obviously
sure it's damping here
okay
what are they gonna do if they get also
can we oh Sprint can we really sneak
around in our own ship like wouldn't you
just go straight to the cockpit
did I do something illegal
what are you gonna do oh that's her
so there are terrorist organizations
oh that's cool
okay that's gameplay I was like
something gonna happen
very very smooth uh transitions here I
don't know if you've heard of a no-cut
camera but uh
all right let's jump
oh boy
the upper body strength you've got my
head
very impressive
come on
oh so he's really just doing great in
that seat we gotta Ripple on him
oh no
yeah it seems pretty bad
you are not authorized for re-entry
sorry but I got no choice well
boost the anti-grass already at maximum
We're not gonna make it yes we are can I
can I fly oh my God I'm flying did I am
I controlling this oh I didn't even
realize
again seamless I'd love to see it hi
Ollie hello welcome good morning
nice to see you here friends
uh you missed out why did you go here um
Crash Landing unintentional
see Dad is your friend dead you said not
to worry it seems that seems ominous
he's probably dead
Max
so
having to get him medical help would be
a great
forward thrust
you're cool
you know
oh God
hey hey come on come on
this is a whole lot more of this Pawn on
it so don't lose this
very special to me it's been many hours
with this
oh
oh
One Life sign detected
continuing search
black iron security you the pilot
this is a very good opening in my
opinion
yay uh
get you out of here
manifest says you were running cargo out
of the hangar don't get many of you
Freelancers out here
foreign
just died
it's kind of my fault
grab him too
hi what are you doing
hey I didn't do anything
that's a dope opening
super well paced really fast good
tutorialization
not super scary but definitely a
Showcase of how scary it can be I think
I jumped twice and got scared by um to
freaked out by uh the bits of cloth so
definitely uh
a good opener a lot of horror games I
think take a little bit too long to get
the [ __ ] why
way too late
okay
unless they are supposed
it just looks like him
was attacked by the outer weight by her
she crashed my ship and she killed my
first time
the only place where you truly
be able to find the one thing that has
always been missing
missing a purpose for your meaningless
[ __ ] you don't know me
find them
welcome to Black Iron prison
I just love that last part
it chills every time yeah end of the
line get up
sounds very good at what he does
and mates
I gave you a direct order this is not
right I don't belong here
you know they call Kalisto the dead Moon
dead just like you would have been
invited and fished you out of that wreck
I mean [ __ ]
as far as anyone else is concerned you
are dead
time
crossing over to
me great whatever it is you're holding
on to right there that's your old life
you gotta let that go because your new
life
is entirely
kind of kinky sort of hot soda hot whoa
what
is that like spinal control or something
forever that's cool thank you MPR rights
and dark Portuguese very nice and Ollie
thank you
Corrections
okay
this is a bit extreme human rights
anybody uh can I get a h in the chat for
human rights inmate 5-3
32-521 Calista protocol said no humidity
doctor he's not in the system we don't
know let's prep the device what the [ __ ]
that device no no you're a goddamn
doctor
my attention to his spine
oh there's gonna be a chip or a brand
that's not so bad
it's not so bad
I mean it's still pretty bad still hates
the human rights still HP numbers sorry
h
uh
doctor he's Flappy gotten uh definitely
some Quake Vibes here too for sure
you're welcome
so now it's Prison Break the video game
yeah spinal stuff is a specific kind of
body horrificial Infamous n89 it is
it is something
hmm interesting
a little blur on the ends oh
five three two five two one new inmate
detected lights out at 1700 hours
very impressed by this dude's face
I meant like graphically but it sounds
like I'm hitting on him that's that's
the that's how you get chicks just super
impressed by your face
that said actually I do think that would
work as a pickup line because it's kind
of quirky he said like hey nice space
um I think people are more likely to
respond to that
okay I don't seem to be
okay cool
uh this is the thing we saw on the
street at the stop
I believe
yeah that one's going to be with you for
a while my guy
so that's the health ball then huh
back of the neck that's great
all right
this is my first time ever screening in
the morning show it what welcome
oh yeah the cool jacket is gone that's a
butler
all right where are we going boys
good for me I guess convenient
Well for now
we're lost
error
oh buddy buddy you're on fire buddy no
prisoners
this room is EU friendly I mean it's
also America friendly I mostly stream on
Australian time funnily enough
by accident
no it's nice I might occasionally try to
do morning streams but my my schedule's
just been such a mess lately I'm pretty
burnt out y'all I'm gonna be honest
happy to be here playing video games
with you at 7am
just uh walking too much at the moment
not Santa Monica is called my own fault
all right mate how's it going
I don't know what the hell
up here and then I woke up to this
you're that pilot I just put in yeah
yeah look I've been in here half my life
I know this place Jesus plan to get out
if you help me out yourself I'll help
you yeah
just to get inside of control across
that bridge you can open myself from
there
Jacob don't lose it Jacob to save your
life
all right we have a shank
that would make me think combat is
coming
hey bud just hang on I gotta scope out
the ship first you understand you
understand
always judge video game by its Flames
not a huge fan of these flames
I have this very specific stupid thing
where I you shouldn't care about Flames
who cares but I'm always like is the
other Flames 2D they are
um
it really doesn't matter I always look
all right Elias
we go shank somebody and I'll be right
back
no worries broth
I've got you in it
very handy I would not have known to do
that oh okay
wouldn't wouldn't have um you are much
craftier than I
was a 2d in real life
sorry good point
there's an Aussie on board is there
hmm
this um got out of hand real fast
this game is very good looking though
which I think we knew from the gameplay
how did you light on fire oil what is
sustaining this fire of this metal thing
so I wonder if oxygen is going to be a
problem this game I have this um
very convenient thing for all these that
I've worked in games media where I will
do a reaction video and read all the
Articles regarding news for a game and
then forget all of it uh like while I'm
reading it I'm like that sounds really
cool I'm excited about that and then
I'll completely forget everything that I
read which I think I may have trained
myself to do because it means that I
don't know what to expect when I'm
playing something um I didn't do that
when I was a journalist obviously but
now I'm like
um
yeah so everything's always fresh and
unexpected
so I have to see what direction they're
about to hit me from
yeah I like that that's cool I do need
to tie that off my thumbs
oh my God
foreign
I stopped hitting it just to see oh well
he said stop White
all right well we have some fundamental
differences here
oh it's a spooky scary
is there like a lock on
oh they take a long time to kill
oh my God
in the tutorial
that happened so fast
oh my
that happens so quickly
okay let me um uh accessibility
I need to get rid of
[Music]
it would be that
that this is so cool that's a cool
option these are all cool options yeah
if anyone here's another reason I care
so much about accessibility is okay and
at this point it's brought up but my
interest began with I can't do any rapid
uh button Taps um in video games I have
tendonitis in both my wrists so
I basically just can't move my thumbs
quickly
um and for any game that I do have to it
ends up getting really painful so
all right
try that again
this is gonna be tough
that thing took that one to kill I mean
I guess I wasn't dodging at all but
still
let's do it again
give it a try the direction you judge
doesn't matter oh really
oh that's interesting
oh you know what I was also doing it
with the right stick or something so
that's on me
foreign
he said stop wait
just let's just see what happens
probably nothing
Thank You Phillip Stone
it's not gonna work is it there's no way
there's no way all right fine
I didn't want to kill you so
the things this man is saying why we do
not align
all right let's try touching
no it didn't work
you have to hold it
I'm dodging though why is touching not
working
maybe
oh my God
okay you have to hold it down further
maybe to be clear that was me testing it
more than anything rather than really
trying okay so
um I'm gonna try it again I don't mind
if I die I gotta learn how the Dodge
works
foreign
which I'm going to try again so
apologies if it sucks to watch if I die
again but I want to make sure that I do
it correctly
I'm just gonna try and Dodge a punch it
fast
you can't Dodge in the same direction
more than once
is that true
okay we'll figure it out I'm just gonna
test it like I said
because I would want to make sure that I
understand it before I get out of the on
that tutorial
good morning Amanda oh Big Stretch sorry
but I have to kill you I would love to
stop and wait but um
I don't make the rules
[Applause]
all right let's try dodging in
multiple
directions
just want to learn how it works nope
still no huh okay
I definitely need to figure this out
okay
no I did it I did it in the same
direction twice there so that worked
and not there
why though
what am I doing differently
this is getting different animations oh
my God
okay not clear on how dodging work I did
it twice in the same direction and it
worked
you have to hold it until the animation
is finished I think I did and you have
to alternate directions for his two hit
combo I didn't and it worked though
not holding the stick long enough I was
holding it down the whole time though
you should Dodge dodging
hmm
I just want to learn man
yeah I don't think not holding it down
for long enough was the problem because
I looked the same length every time and
it worked the first two times
I'm judging towards the direction the
heat is coming from uh no way from it I
think
I'm not sure it's a good question
if it worked when you hit it twice in
the same direction that's not a tend to
behavior yeah it did
that was actually the only way it worked
when I did it alternating it didn't work
um
just want to make sure I understand you
know what I'm saying it seems important
I'm sure I could just beat him and
frantically Dodge away but I would
prefer to like properly know how to do
it
again sorry to make you watch this again
it's probably gonna happen again I'm not
trying to kill him I'm trying to lie to
dodge sorry I'm really sorry again he
does not represent My Views I didn't
have a choice by choice he would not
have done that I'm sorry
not you want me
not you or me don't agree with him at
all
okay one more time let's go
didn't work
that one worked
I really don't know man but I also don't
think I'm Gonna Learn I really don't
know
because I was doing left and right I was
holding it the whole way and sometimes
he just attacks me
that doesn't feel good I really should
have I should have died again
we'll figure it out eventually I guess
hey
we'll figure it out hopefully the
checkpoints are good uh
so that when I continue to
die it works out okay
but yeah it's not quite following
the rules there
oh you brought come out of your prison
so yeah no that's sick in it bloody
Earth mate
hold left stick why are you telling me
this right now
okay hold the left stick to the left or
right before the enemy attacks to dodge
it yep there isn't a timing window just
be holding left or right before the
enemy hits you
oh
that's interesting
so
you can kind of do it at any time
you don't need to dodge the same way he
hits also it's kind of regular sometimes
he'll hit regardless maybe that was the
problem
maybe that was the problem so it's not a
timing based thing you just have to be
holding that direction which means I'll
probably just always hold that direction
right I'll always hold a Direction
to dodge a series Amelia attacks let me
just let you all read this too just
to to dodge a series of melee attacks
hold the left stick in One Direction
before the enemy attacks then ship to
hold the left stick in the other
direction alternating between sides
never dodged in the same direction while
the monster of the sequence will fail I
mean it says that but it didn't
oh well
maybe that was like it didn't count it
as a sequence because I stopped in the
middle potentially
it's a good question why are we learning
this now that's okay we'll figure it out
we'll see early Little Pantry oh my God
you look so cute I'm sorry I have to
give you a little banjo break okay just
give me one second everybody this is
super important okay I promise you this
is super important
so you can see how cute he looks
look at him
look at the little dog look at the dog
oh my God
oh my gosh
she's laying on his own Paws oh the
cutest boy okay
back to the game all right so not timing
base it's good to know I do love the
timing based pirate system but that that
is cool I like it being the stick too to
be honest rather than a bumper
um
do opposite directions
we'll just take the deaths until we
figure it out that's okay
it's just
hey you open me
or is he coming to Me Maybe
what did I do open someone else's cell
nothing I think
no he's already out all right oh nope
it's supposed to be
letting it through
I don't know what I'm doing
I'm just hitting a
what you hitting bud
sort of just the desk
and then that happens
who knows man all right
how do we open this
the only thing I can interact with here
is that a button
I think
God this game looks so good
it's the only thing okay
what is that
somebody shooting
who knows
kick the dead for loot you say
how do I kick
I don't know what kick is it's not
taught me that
uh the big door was unlocked the whole
time actually
oh kick is why
oh wow that's that's a hell of a stall
I don't know if I can get anything out
of it yet though oh my god oh I can from
this one I will take the health cell
cool good to know thank you
can I like disintegrate the whole thing
oh I decapitated that guy huh
damn wow
[Music]
okay
great
expected it to prompt me to press a
because it did when I came in but it
didn't on the way out so I was expecting
to Auto open
uh all right let's go finalize in it
bloody oath
oh man
what is that noise
turrets
oh it's the robot
all right where'd my makeup
over here in this case no good console's
not restored back there I just saw
something
you want about it I know what I saw look
this place can mess with your head but
this is our chance whatever it was you
saw it's all the more reason to get out
of it see that Watchtower
yeah that's our first stop we be there
ow elevators that way take it up to the
next level I'll be in touch got it
okay let's go
use the lighting
I wonder if I can avoid them
probably not right I'm gonna have to
fight this
oh hey you
okay
no problem Oh there's two of them [ __ ]
no that's not
that was lighting
okay in a weird way this is a this is a
oh
yeah okay so in a weird way
um the dodging
um
it's gonna be pretty slow every time so
I wonder what groups are gonna be like I
feel like it's gonna be really hard it's
kind of like a fighting game
and that makes it make sense to me and
that you just have to hold back all the
time to block right so it's like even
when they're not immediately attacking
you you just have to hold let him swing
at you maybe twice then you can hit him
twice and show them different enemies
will do different things or at least
hopefully but uh yeah if I think if I
think of it like a fighting game it'll
make more sense to me than
thinking of it as a blocking or Parry
system
yeah and that makes it make sense but we
can't be taking hits every fight let me
tell you what I'm gonna get very far
okay
so wait stepping back is block and left
and right is dodged that's what I mean
anyway right if I go left and right
I'm still saying the same thing it's
like just instead of holding back in a
fighting game you're holding left or
right at all times pretty much and I
think that will work uh I didn't pay any
attention to what the student just said
to me sorry what
I probably should have listened to that
um
sorry man I was talking to my friends on
the internet
this way I think I have to just go back
right surely
whatever that green thing is I wanted
I would really like to have that
he said take elevator am I not on the
elevator
did I already take it
that's what happens when you play games
while streaming am I in a different part
of the map now I don't know
God it does look really good man
okay this is different trolley this is
different
it is
my music's well we've been over this I
don't like it
we all
me
array we are all going to die
hopeful great
okay cool hey you got anything for me
sorry about your corpse help please
never mind
oh I'm getting that green thing
hello
I love you
won't you tell me your name
all right [ __ ] this could go real badly
to me so
foreign
so the problem with it is that
um
obviously it makes sense to me now I get
it we've got the dodging down
um if it's like that every time it could
get pretty repetitive that said
obviously they're just showing me
enemies one-on-one to make sure I got
the dodging down which took care I did
so it worked
but uh I'm curious to see what it looks
like in a group
oh it's like a little
the robot sounded creepy it's like a
little um Pokemon potion
look for wall mounted boxes that contain
a health injector enemies can drop
Health injectors and they can also be
found inside loot crates
press the d-pad down and quickly use a
health injector they will replenish
Health but use with cat as you can be a
tech Journey oh cool injection process
Health injectors can also be used by the
inventory screen
down on the d-pad you say
to hold it down
I'm gonna take that we don't need to
look at it but speed up that process we
don't need to be looking at it when we
do that all right my guy okay uh did I
curb stomp this dude
I did oh my God
gross I love
they fall apart
[Laughter]
ticket you've heard scallops review I
have not
um I think I already said this but I
have not uh set at the start of the
video watched any reviews because I was
so excited about this game
obviously it's still like some Whispers
of people's Impressions on the internet
but I just wanted to go in crush without
anybody anybody else's input so
I did not watch any to be fair I don't
watch reviews anyway
love uh love skill up but uh have I have
not actually watched any of his reviews
um
but no for this particularly I was
really trying to avoid them
this feels like when maybe going down
with the elevator I'm heading down not
up Watch Tower up
great
all right
sounds fun let's do it
did I just stop the game I did we've
been playing for about 45 minutes or so
I think
that's cool I will say it's a little bit
washed out and I wonder if maybe that I
made it too bright but otherwise this
game is like this is beautiful this has
to be one of the best looking games in
the year
um Graphics probably
I'm just gonna take the brightness down
see the thing is not visible to me but
it could be just that my monitor is
playing tricks on me then maybe try that
no it's still washed out might be a HDR
issue potentially
which oh okay
uh what difficulty am I playing on I'm
playing on normal
I uh generally play pretty much every
game on normal these days I used to play
every game on hard
that was when I had more time
I'd say most of my video gaming time has
been spent on hard and then I became an
adult here I am
cruising on normal
never really play things on easy though
unless it's something where I don't like
the combat then all really easy but
that's not super common
I'm just blown away by how pretty this
is
sorry if anybody has any light
sensitivity
Jacob
I didn't like that very much
but also who said that are we gonna
contextualize that why is there so much
blood
there's a man up there oh God wait I can
sell things there's a vendor
or is it in the menu uh
menu menu
foreign
why are there so many unknown Persons of
Interest it's interesting
I'm guessing that there's gonna be like
a bioshocky type system
doing a playlist listen for the game
awards this week
um we are doing playlist listen this
week but it'll be recorded before the
game awards so
it'll still go up on Friday then
nothing to see it all right all right
all right
you go art team
Kalisto credits
you
why
judge game bites toilets ladies and
gentlemen
hello map show welcome
nice to see you here
um I you know those little bits of the
toilet rolls that uh Brown I give them
to my dog and he has a great time
every time he's like oh the toilet roll
is done a toy by banjo
very excited
scoop this out
am I going crazy
that's very uh Dead Space what's his
name cava
this looks breakable nice
look at me gaming
my dad worked in a prison for a while
whoa oh my gosh thank you for the the
subs pojo DLC thank you so much
thank you thank you thank you I
appreciate you so much thank you
for you we're having a wonderful morning
thanks for stopping by
I'm not sure what the charity we're
going to be raising money for this month
is uh if you're new here I donate twitch
money to charity
um probably something
to do with
homelessness or food banks
uh being that it is the holiday season a
lot of people out there need a lot of
help
cool I don't know why I'm not finding
this scary you know
I could not tell you why I'm not finding
this hair
this seems like something I should be
scared of I get very scared of video
games
it's an interesting thing to think about
um
[Music]
I'm sure I'm sure it'll get worse
but strangely I'm not scared and I don't
know why like all of the DNA's there
beautiful realistic
creepy aggressive enemies
oddly not scared maybe it's the time of
day I'm playing maybe playing a spooky
game at 8am it was the wrong call
I'm like huh what a beautiful day
Sonic California it's actually pretty
overcast
good toilet content thank you oh God
it's so gross man
all right
design choice that door that said unlock
that it didn't have the a prompt was an
odd it was an odd choice
oh thank you so much for sharing that
all right thank you
okay why my bad sorry about that
um
very scone of you
on patrol
it's really the most British man of all
time
oh my God okay
just said I wasn't scared I did not
expect that
what the hell
no concept of that
coming at all
I'm not scared actually I'm totally fine
oh my God I did not expect that Jesus
also is my audio out of sync audio audio
audio probably tiny bit hanger
hello hello hello hello that seems
better
not scared a lot of PS ladies and
gentlemen notoriously not afraid of
video games let's go
uh for all the conversations people have
about how my accent has or hasn't
changed I think it has a little bit but
I never had a very strong Australian
accent so most people who say you don't
sound Australian
um
probably would have said the same thing
about me when I was still in Australia
the word that I think has shown the
change in my accent the most is games I
used to say games
the and this is not going to sound
different to most of you but to always
it'll make sense I say games I used to
say games it's like in the back of my
throat video games but now I say video
games
sound more Australian than Ross maybe
Ross has lost the r sounds which I don't
think I will ever lose
whereas my vows are a little bit
different and yeah Ross and I have
changed different parts of accents
that's rubber Ross everybody
um of Game Grumps Fame also in good game
as I was
that doesn't sound great
it was inconsequential it was just noise
okay odd
if I can hear something walking
that was a strange fake out
oh don't mind if I do
oh thank you so much God I know I
probably missed it I'm sorry
thank you I really appreciate it have a
wonderful day yeah obviously
accessibility is of course is very
important to me
um very very proud of the accessibility
team and all of our Consultants who
worked on go to Ragnarok
I I appreciate you noticing
no no we're not infected
yikes okay we've got an alien isolation
situation area secured
the robots are the bigger threat
good to know
oh there is still okay yeah very alien
isolation which I love
we are down with alien isolation
I just hope it's not as long I really do
feel like that game is too long
it's got to be this way surely oh
I could have taken me forever to find no
movement detected I love their voice
no movement detected
all right
I
I don't want to make you guys mad oh hey
Susie welcome I don't want to make you
guys mad
to watch me die but I'm gonna do it I'm
gonna let it kill me because I want to
see what it looks like okay you guys
ready I want to see it absolutely
destroy me kill me Daddy
smashed my face in do it do it do it
oh she Mysteries
inmate you will comply
it's so long oh my God
oh my God
oh that was like five seconds
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ]
oh my God
it's like
it's not like okay we're gonna tell you
limbs off I thought it was gonna like
punch me through the stomach it's not
like we're gonna tell you limbs off it's
like we're gonna tear your limbs off and
then smash your head in oh my God
oh boy spicy
okay keep moving and try not to let that
happen again though I would love to see
all the variations maybe I'll um do a
playthrough off stream where I just let
things kill me as much as possible
because I was definitely a part of this
sort of field to me before it came out
just avoid them bro
come on bro
you just gotta stay out alive in it what
my best mate just died
all right okay lad
you turn around I swear to God
thick Daddy
you stay right there authorized lethal
Force authorized I love the way they
said oh
he's got no activity detected dude it's
such a cool voice
um could you keep moving thick King I'm
not trying to get up in your business at
all
well I was actually going to go that way
so if you could keep moving but to the
left
they sound kind of hot is it weird it is
weird I pretend I didn't ask it's
definitely weird
am I supposed to be attracted to the
robots
uh that's an a again about the a problem
all systems nominal
Oh I thought this would take me to a
different room
oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no okay
uh well it's fine again scanning for
active core signature no you want
scanning folks
something else to do
again even if he kills me though it'll
be exciting
okay
it's it's all good I get a new six
second death animation
what you looking at what
you what's your peepers see
I don't know it's staying low is really
going to help us damage there
weapon systems online weapon systems
online
I love it
I want to know who did the voices
I am a hot robot
really would love to ask somebody on the
design team the distinction between
which things to press a on
I guess it's not necessary every time
but then why have it at all maybe it's
things that say unlocked on them
that don't have a because that would
replace needing to press a
quake
that's that's the most Quake machine
I've ever seen in my life
it's pretty big uh I don't need help
okay I can just keep better don't use it
great
um I don't have any kind of maps I'm not
sure which way I should be going here
medical award
B m117 John himself
decontamination m one two two
incinerator m one two three that's
beautiful lighting that's nice that's a
nice looking that's a good looking ass
hallway right there
that is look just get rid of me
I'll just do this
damn [ __ ]
that's pretty
mm-hmm
Jonathan Callisto and John 107 the best
friends it checks out yeah
John 1 1 7.
is this the place where you get free
implants
I actually don't want to go that way yet
though oh there's too much to explore
intensive care wait that's probably
where I came from
oh my God
it's too big
it's too big
nobody clipped that
try to look up the voice actor of the
robot and even in game credits it's his
second review of Costless
so this is me doing a circle I think is
the robot just gone from here now
sorry dude I gotta see if you got any
[ __ ] on your butt you got anything for
me no okay I recognize that I could have
just spent down to check but is curb
stop is much more fun
ah I don't know where to go oh no
there's too many options
I'm proper stressed about this okay who
cares just keep playing the game this is
clearly where it wants me to go because
it's spectacle
but
I would love to explore
what was it a gate fuse
oh it's pretty dark in here it's quite
dark
yes I would like it to be
free implants
oh I really like the
the realism of the projections is cool
to see
I didn't even see it
I will take that out thank you thank you
thank you thank you
okay yeah these are very cool projected
images
what's that a lung is it lost Rick's 54
yes all right we've got too many anyway
bloody hell
medical one is now locked huh
okay so it is dude the lighting oh
whoever did the lighting in this video
game
oh Okay let's listen to Caitlyn Miller
no wrong one it's um it's
it's right on the d-pad
that's this no I've forgotten x a uh
it's up okay
to Caitlyn
me to restart the program
it won't be easy but I trust in my team
they as I
understand the promise here
all right it wasn't a ton of information
appreciate it though
[Music]
okay
I still want to know what the word
mezzanine means you know I know they
exist
I'm aware of them
is mezzanine like a ground floor
still not entirely sure
okay mate how's it going
okay well I was blocking that one but
all right if you say so
[Music]
and that one
what did I do wrong
why did it not work
maybe I was holding it too late
hmm
sorry about your arm
thanks for the credits what did you need
those for I guess they were humans huh
all right let's keep going
God I'm so impressed with the way this
looks
look at him covered in blood too
it's another good looking hallway also
based on time I'm going to leave this
there for YouTube because I upload the
first hours on YouTube so I'm gonna
leave it there for YouTube but we're
gonna keep streaming on Twitch
um so if you're watching the YouTube
video whenever I upload it I'll leave a
link to where the VOD is because I'll
post the rest of the hours that I
continue to play on my stream upload
channel so say goodbye to YouTube
everybody
but I'm gonna continue playing
for another several hours at this point
and I will yeah upload that where I
upload my my stream votes
um
so by YouTube